- Welcome back everybody.
It's the part of the
show where I present you
with something delightful
from the internet.
This is What I'm Liking.
(jaunty music, crowd
cheering and clapping)
Visitors in Telluride, Colorado
are having an amazing day
because it's an awesome place,
just to start with that.
But they were stunned when a bear
dashed through a resort
chased by a police officer.
The incident was caught on video,
but one woman, she's my personal hero,
was the only one to ask the
really important question.
Take a look.
(crowd of onlookers
gasping and chattering)
- [Male Onlooker] Holy shit.
- [Grace] Oh my God.
- [Male Onlooker] Don't
tase it, don't tase it.
- [Grace] Is that Jeff?
The hot cop?
(audience laughs and claps)
- Is that, wait, there's
like a deadly animal.
She's like, wait, is
that Jeff, the hot cop?
Go chase him. (laughs)
And did you catch it, it is amazing.
Oh my God, let's play it one more time.
I just love it.
(group of onlookers gasps and chatters)
- [Male Onlooker] Holy shit.
- [Grace] Oh my God.
- [Male Onlooker] Don't
tase it, don't tase it.
- [Grace] Is that Jeff?
The hot cop?
- (laughing) It's my favorite
What I'm Liking we've ever done.
The hot cop.
I want to have drinks with her.
This girl, she knew her priorities.
She knew what was important.
Her name is Grace.
She's awesome.
And we have her on the line right now
watching on Denver 7 at 2pm.
So first and foremost, I love you.
And no one was hurt, right?
- Hi Kelly, I love you too.
Fortunately, no one was injured.
Jeff did not end up tasing the bear,
So that's good news
for everyone, hey guys.
Especially the guy that
was screaming behind me.
- (laughing) I mean, I play that so often.
It's like is that Jeff, the hot cop?
So what's up with Jeff.
Any chance with Jeff?
- I did post a few
follow ups on my Tik Tok,
sharing the news that he's married.
- [Kelly] Oh, okay.
- But even though he's off the market,
I'm still hoping to
find someone to cuff me.
- [Kelly] (laughing and clapping)
Did she say, did you say cuff me?
Oh my God, you have got to come in studio
for an interview, I love you so much.
Jeff is taken, we're looking
for the other Jeff though.
He's out there, I believe it.
I really want you to
come on my show in person
just to hang out and have some wine
or whatever you want to drink.
Thank you so much, Grace.
You are so awesome.
And one of a kind and
I love where you live.
It's beautiful.
Telluride is one of the
most beautiful places.
All right, I'm liking
your posts right now.
- [Grace] Any time.
(audience applauds)
Well, that's not all Grace,
our season-long partner Pilot Pen,
the go-to pen of the Kelly Clarkson show
thinks your video is hilarious.
I don't know, I doubt they
think it's funny as I do.
So they'll be using their
G2 gel ink pen to write
you a check for a thousand dollars.
How's that sound?
(audience claps and cheers)
(Kelly laughs)
It's not Jeff, the hot cop,
but it'll buy you some fun stuff.